trips I did something that you told me
not to do Joe Rogan you ready for this
you told me not to do it years ago and I
did it and it was rough and I performed
stand-up comedy in Connecticut right you
were right dude
I told you it's a place of despair it's
really crazy so one of the things that
happened was is I noticed this really
cool old guy stood out in the front
middle of the audience right and I'm
like you seem like out of place and cool
as hell and old as [ __ ] what's your
story dude right and I noticed that
there's this angry older lady almost
like almost like Dana Carvey is like
church lady character sitting next to
him and I go and who's this angry lady
that you're sitting next to
she doesn't want to be here at all
and he goes that's my wife and they were
the most different seeming couple you
could ever imagine this happy smiling
laughing and everything guy in just this
I mean she was looking at me with hate
not just not having fun she hated me it
could have been something that I talked
about early on maybe it was like a
something about oh you're Amy Schumer
Joe could have been that could have been
my me too Joe could have been my trump
misdirect joke that people you know what
I mean anyway
and but I noticed next to them there's
this girl who seems even angrier than
the mom and they're the only two angry
people in the room and it's a gig at a
casino she'll be there Connecticut give
me a face just literally like literally
like a modern day like if someone said
to a bad actress like play angry play
angry anger to a horrible actress like
that and and and I go and I go what's
the problem and you know there's like
dude we're I ignore it for like 45
minutes right and I'm going on and on
but the moms angry it turns out that the
chick next to them is the daughter and
then they're basically mad because of
whatever whatever material or whatever
and I end up towards the end of my set
going off on the girl I go I go
take this scowl off your face what are
you doing do you think that's going to
affect me lady I'm getting paid the same
amount whether you laugh or not and I'm
back to LA back to the dream tomorrow
you know what I mean like at this point
I'm just my fans are loving it and
they're the ones that stumbled into the
wrong casino for the wrong show at the
wrong time if they were looking for
Christian puppet comedy or whatever and
I said to her I go you seem like I I go
well I go you seem like an internet
troll that just stumbled in here like
you seem like you're gonna write about
this you seem ain't like the type of
angry where you think you're gonna
change something or you're gonna do
something to my career that's what I
that's the vibe I get from you I
literally made the jokes the crowds
loving it by the way you know what I
mean cuz they can tell like it's not
saying anything to your shoes there was
one there was one part where I go I go
Mike because my goal the the thing that
the reason why I ignored them for a
while was because I go you seem like a
tough lady to the mom right I go you
seem tough but I'm gonna break you at
some point during this set and when I do
I'm gonna make sure this whole room
knows I'm gonna say I gotcha and I'm not
gonna tell you when it's gonna happen
but I'm gonna make you laugh anyway 45
minutes later I get to the point to
where I had in my mind set up that
there's no way she's not going to laugh
at this and sure enough I got a big
smile out of her right I'm not I won't
say what the joke is I don't want to
give anything away but I got the smile
and I'm literally like and the whole
crowds already laughing and they can
tell that I'm looking to watch to see if
the lady breaks and she doesn't and I go
how and though I thought I was gonna get
you I was gonna get you on that one how
is it possible that you don't laugh at
that like what do you do for fun lady
like at this point I'm just right all
amped up and I go what would I have to
do to possibly make you laugh and that's
finally when the angry daughter goes be
funny
I go oh no I've been killing for 52
minutes now you know what I mean like at
this point whatever there's everybody
else the 99.9% of the other audience is
the witness at this point and they're
against this chick right cuz this chicks
now just mad because whatever and and I
go you seem like the type of girl that
thinks that you can even affect an
artist you know what I mean this is this
little millennial nerdy girl and sure
enough sure enough I go on Twitter later
that night they're at Mohegan Sun you
should not be promoting this comedian
bah bah bah two days later my manager
gets an email and he's like dude we got
this email from some lady in Connecticut
says you're being mean to her on stage
she wrote you a letter he's like it's
three paragraphs long like what is
happening like I mean what is happening
in this world where someone's taking the
time to write a letter to my manager of
all people who by the way is laughing at
the whole thing imagine if your manager
dumped you for that you know right one
audience member in Connecticut and that
hold the crowd
99% thought you're funny but that's not
good enough yeah I need a hundred
percent but man you were right and and
Connecticut is weird it's a weird place
you could run into a person like that
anywhere yeah I mean I've run into
people like that at the store they sit
in the front row with their arms crossed
you're gonna run into people like that
everywhere yeah but there's something
about Connecticut where it's there's no
real cities you got Hartford which is a
land of despair and you got New Haven
which is worse and it's just a highway
between Boston in New York it's all it
is yeah Boston's great New York's great
Connecticut's like what the [ __ ] are you
doing here what's going on here it's
become such a running joke the Lex
Friedman the scientist from MIT who's on
here the other day to talk about
artificial intelligence he brought it up
as a joke What did he say
do you member what he said something
about like he just wanted you to [ __ ] on
it did so many gigs in Connecticut so
many
so many because I lived in Boston it was
like it you know hour-and-a-half Drive
yeah two-hour drive you're in
Connecticut we did a lot of gigs there
Greg Fitzsimmons and I we did a [ __ ] ton
of gigs in Connecticut
we'd always leave gone with the [ __ ] it
was it felt it felt dirty it's a gig I
did purely for the money